Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. This episode is brought to you by DZONE. For the first time ever, the 32 best soccer clubs from across the world are coming together to decide who the undisputed champions of the world are in the FIFA Club World Cup. The world's best players, Messi, Holland, Kane and more are all taking part. And you can watch every match for free on Dazon, starting on June 14th and running until July 13th. Sign up now at dazon.com slash FIFA. That's D-A-Z-N dot com slash fifa.
感谢您收听《历史其余部分》。想要获取每周的独家播客、无广告收听、系列的抢先体验权限以及我们备受喜爱的聊天社区的会员资格，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。本集由 DZN 赞助播出。来自全球最好的 32 支足球俱乐部历史上首次汇聚一堂，在国际足联俱乐部世界杯中决出无可争议的世界冠军。梅西、哈兰德、凯恩等世界顶级球员都将参加。您可以在 6 月 14 日至 7 月 13 日期间在 Dazn 上免费观看每一场比赛。立即访问 dazon.com 斜杠 FIFA 注册。网址是 D-A-Z-N 点 com 斜杠 fifa。
What's better than a well marbled ribeye sizzling on the barbecue? A well marbled ribeye sizzling on the barbecue that was carefully selected by an Instacart shopper and delivered to your door. A well marbled ribeye you ordered without even leaving the kiddie pool. Whatever groceries your summer calls for, Instacart has you covered. Download the Instacart app and enjoy $0 delivery fees on your first three orders. Service fees, exclusions, and terms apply. Instacart, groceries that over-deliver. My dear Miss Collins, don't let them make you miserable about it. How could a born soldier die better than at the victorious end of a good fight, falling to the shot of another
有什么能比一块在烤架上滋滋作响、大理石纹理完美的肋眼牛排更好呢？是一块由 Instacart 采购员精心挑选并送到您家门口的、在烤架上滋滋作响的大理石纹理完美的肋眼牛排。是一块您甚至不用离开儿童戏水池就能下单的大理石纹理完美的肋眼牛排。无论您的夏天需要什么杂货，Instacart 都能满足您的需求。下载 Instacart 应用，前三单享受免配送费优惠。服务费、排除条款和适用条款。Instacart，超值交付的杂货。我亲爱的柯林斯小姐，别让他们为此让您感到痛苦。一个天生的士兵，怎么能比在好斗争的胜利终点死得更好呢？倒在另一个
Irishman, a damn fool, but all the same an Irishman who thought he was fighting for Ireland, a Roman to a Roman. I met Michael for the first and last time on Saturday last and I'm very glad I did. I rejoice in his memory. I will not be so disloyal as to snivel over his valiant death. So treat up your mourning and hang up your brightest colours in his honour. Let us all praise God that he did not die in a snuffy bed of a trumpery cough, weakened by age and saddened by the disappointments that would have attended his work had he lived. So that, ladies and gentlemen, was original authentic archive of George Bernard Shaw writing
爱尔兰人的枪下，一个该死的傻瓜，但归根结底是一个认为自己在为爱尔兰战斗的爱尔兰人，罗马人对罗马人。我上星期六第一次也是最后一次见到迈克尔，我很高兴我去了。我为他的记忆感到高兴。我不会那么不忠，为他英勇的死而哭哭啼啼。所以，请振作起你的哀悼，挂上你最鲜艳的颜色来纪念他。让我们大家赞美上帝，他没有死在无聊的咳嗽声中，因年老而虚弱，并因他活着时本应伴随他的工作的失望而感到悲伤。所以，女士们先生们，那是乔治·伯纳德·沙、
to Hannie Collins, the sister of Michael Collins, on the 25th of August 1922 and three days earlier. Michael Collins, surely the most charismatic of all Ireland's independence heroes, the director of intelligence of the Irish Republican Army, signatory to the Anglo-Irish Treaty and then the head of government, the provisional government of the Irish Free State and commander of its national army. He had been shot dead by his former comrades at a crossroads near Bail na Blor in rural County Cork. Tom, you know, I'm a great fan of County Cork and this is one of the most hotly debated moments in all Irish history, isn't it? Some people see it as a tragedy, others see it as, you know, Collins got his just desserts. A massive turning point in Ireland's history.
写给迈克尔·柯林斯的姐姐汉妮·柯林斯的原始真实档案，时间是 1922 年 8 月 25 日，也就是三天前。迈克尔·柯林斯，无疑是爱尔兰所有独立英雄中最具个人魅力的一个，爱尔兰共和军的情报主管，英爱条约的签署国，然后是爱尔兰自由邦临时政府的首脑及其国民军的司令。他在科克郡乡村拜纳布洛附近的一个十字路口被前战友枪杀。汤姆，你知道，我是科克郡的超级粉丝，这是整个爱尔兰历史中最受激烈辩论的时刻之一，对吧？有些人认为这是一场悲剧，另一些人认为，你知道，柯林斯是罪有应得。爱尔兰历史上一个巨大的转折点。
Well is it? We'll discuss that, whether Collins would have set Ireland on a different course. But certainly, it is the most emblematic moment in this terrible conflict, which follows on directly from the Irish War of Independence. And you see people who'd been fighting the British turning on themselves. And it's a moment in
嗯，是吗？我们会讨论这个问题，柯林斯是否会让爱尔兰走上不同的道路。但毫无疑问，这是这场可怕冲突中最具象征意义的时刻，这场冲突直接延续自爱尔兰独立战争。你可以看到那些曾与英国人战斗的人将枪口转向了自己。这是一个在
Irish history that is much less commemorated in Irish memory for obvious reasons, because all the romance, all the poetry of the War of Independence, it gets dissolved and crushed and ends up with this kind of squalid moment where the great hero of the Irish War of Independence is lying dead in his own county. Well, I think getting two Oxbridge Englishmen to talk about the Irish Civil War is madness. So the great news is that we're still in the Four Courts in Dublin, which is where the Civil War started. So if you hear Laurie's rumbling past, that is why. But the most exciting thing, we are joined by a great friend of the rest of history,
爱尔兰历史中，出于显而易见的原因，受纪念较少的时刻，因为独立战争中所有的浪漫主义和诗意都被溶解、粉碎，并以这种卑劣的时刻告终：爱尔兰独立战争的伟大英雄躺在自己的郡内死去。好吧，找两个牛津毕业的英国人来谈论爱尔兰内战简直是疯了。所以好消息是，我们仍然在都柏林的四法院，内战就是从这里开始的。所以如果你听到劳里汽车隆隆开过，那就是原因所在。但最令人兴奋的是，我们迎来了一位“历史其余部分”的伟大朋友，
distinguished journalist for the Irish Times, the author of a brilliant book on the assassination of Sir Henry Wilson, great hatred, our pal Ronan McGrievey. Ronan, welcome back to the rest is history. Thank you so much, Dalek. So let's remind ourselves what's been going on. I'll attempt to summarize the world's most complicated historical question in about 40 seconds. So there's been a huge split over the Anglo-Irish treaty, a split both in the Irish nationalist elite and in the Irish Republican army in the early months of 1922. And anti-treaty IRA men have occupied the building we're in right now, the Four Courts.
《爱尔兰时报》杰出记者、关于暗杀亨利·威尔逊爵士的精彩著作《巨大的仇恨》的作者，我们的好朋友罗南·麦格里维。罗南，欢迎回到“历史其余部分”。非常感谢，多米尼克。那么让我们回想一下发生了什么。我试着用大约 40 秒钟总结世界上最复杂的历史问题。因此，在 1922 年初，围绕《英爱条约》发生了巨大分裂，爱尔兰民族主义精英和爱尔兰共和军内部都出现了分裂。反对条约的爱尔兰共和军人员占领了我们现在所在的这座建筑，即四法院。
And Dominic, do you know what the Daily Mail said about this? They said that this sort of thing must stop. Yeah, they were right. Which I think is a very father-tared approach to the complexities of Irish history. So the anti-treaty IRA men have been in this building. The trigger comes when Sir Henry Wilson, as we talked about last time, is assassinated in Belgrave in London. The British, particularly Lloyd George and Churchill, effectively deliver an ultimatum
多米尼克，你知道《每日邮报》对这件事是怎么说的吗？他们说这种事情必须停止。是的，他们说得对。我认为这是以一种老气横秋的态度来对待爱尔兰历史的复杂性。因此，反条约爱尔兰共和军人员一直留在这栋大楼里。导火索是，正如我们上次所讨论的，亨利·威尔逊爵士在伦敦贝尔格雷夫被暗杀。英国人，特别是劳埃德·乔治和丘吉尔，实际上向临时政府发出了最后通牒。
to the provisional government. And we ended last time with these howitzers on the bridges outside where we are now, British guns opening fire and shelling the building. So Ronan, take us through the story. What happens next? Because the fighting lasts for three days I think in this building. So the fighting lasts for three days in the forecourt. First of all, they had to find some people to operate the guns and this is an interesting part of the Civil War is that there's a huge number
我们在上次节目结束时提到了架设在我们在场外部桥梁上的这些榴弹炮，英国大炮开始开火并轰炸这座建筑。罗南，请带我们了解这个故事。接下来发生了什么？因为我认为在这栋大楼里的战斗持续了三天。所以战斗在四法院持续了三天。首先，他们不得不找一些人来操作大炮，内战的一个有趣之处在于，国民军中有大量的
of former British soldiers in the National Army. So initially they hadn't embedded the guns down properly and the shells were flying way over the four courts. They hit the British headquarters on the other side. They did yes and they were very, very inaccurate. But then eventually they did find their range and they started to, a really point blank range, started to make holes in the walls here. And it was a very dangerous thing that they were doing. I mean, they were basically storming the building.
前英国士兵。所以最初他们没有把大炮正确地固定好，炮弹从四法院上方飞了过去。他们击中了另一边的英国总部。他们确实击中了，而且非常非常不准确。但后来他们终于找到了射程，并开始在真正近距离的射程内开始在这里的墙上凿洞。他们所做的事情非常危险。我的意思是，他们基本上是在冲击这座建筑。
But on the third day, just when the garrison inside are, their situation is hopeless, they're not able to escape. The public records office, which is on the site here, is blown up in a massive explosion. Public records office is the Irish National Archive. It's the archive going back to the 12th century and everything in there is destroyed. The census going back to the first part of the pre-Famon census going back to 1821. Chancery records, grants of land, payments made to spies, payments made to headhunters, the records of the various chief secretaries to Ireland, centuries of Church of Ireland parish records. Everything goes up in this massive conflagration. And there's a famous quote in Ernie O'Malley's book.
但在第三天，正当里面的守军情况无望、无法逃脱时，位于这里的公共档案馆在一场巨大的爆炸中被炸毁。公共档案馆就是爱尔兰国家档案馆。那是追溯到 12 世纪的档案馆，里面的所有东西都被摧毁了。可追溯到大饥荒前的第一部分人口普查，可追溯到 1821 年的人口普查。大法官法院记录、土地赠予、支付给间谍的款项、支付给赏金猎人的款项、爱尔兰历任首席秘书的记录、长达数个世纪的爱尔兰教会教区记录。一切都在这场大火中化为灰烬。欧尼·奥马利的书里有一句名言。
Ernie O'Malley was one of the anti-treaty and he was talking about this white rain that was coming down, this paper that was coming down on top of the people of Dublin. So basically the archives were destroyed. That's the most famous thing about the battle for the Four Courts. It lasts three days. The garrison surrenders and the provisional government hopes that's the end of it. But the anti-treaties decide to fight on.
欧尼·奥马利是反条约派的一员，他谈到了这种落下的白色雨，这种落在都柏林人民身上的纸张。所以基本上档案被毁了。这是关于四法院之战最著名的事情。持续了三天。守军投降，临时政府希望事情就此结束。但反条约派决定继续战斗。
So the fight moves to O'Connell Street, which is the site in 1916 where the GPO is located and the whole of the west side of the GPO of McConnell Street had been very badly damaged in the 1916 rise and so now it was the turn of the east side, northeast side where there was a whole hotel complex which was the Dublin IRA was located and so again the 18 pounders are opened up and there's about 80 people killed in Dublin in this time period. And so the battle for Dublin is fairly quick and decisive. And so the anti-treaty rebels take to the countryside.
因此，战斗转移到了奥康奈尔街，这里是 1916 年邮政总局所在地，奥康奈尔街邮政总局的整个西侧在 1916 年起义中受到严重破坏，现在轮到东侧、东北侧了，那里有一个都柏林爱尔兰共和军所在的整个酒店综合体，因此 18 磅炮再次开火，这一时期都柏林大约有 80 人丧生。因此，都柏林战役相当迅速且具有决定性。于是反条约叛军退入乡村。
So to remind people, the IRA had split. On the one hand, you have Michael Collins and Richard Mulcahy and people like that who are commanding what's now called the National Army. Fighting for the provisional government. On the other hand you have I guess De Valera and the other, the IRA Irregulars, their commander is a guy called Liam Lynch who's about 30, 31, very young. 27 I think. So at that point actually if you look at the numbers the anti-treaty people seem to have the up there are more of them right? and they think they're going to win that's right so in March 1922 the anti-treaty IRA said that 80% of their of their members are anti the treaty and they have over almost 13,000 men under arms and
为了提醒大家，爱尔兰共和军已经分裂。一方面，有迈克尔·柯林斯、理查德·穆尔卡希等人指挥现在被称为国民军的军队。为临时政府而战。另一方面，我想是德瓦莱拉和其他人，爱尔兰共和军非正规军，他们的指挥官是一个叫利亚姆·林奇的人，大约 30、31 岁，非常年轻。我想是 27 岁。所以当时实际上如果你看一下数字，反条约派似乎占据上风，他们人更多对吧？他们认为他们会赢，对的，所以在 1922 年 3 月，反条约爱尔兰共和军表示，他们 80% 的成员反对该条约，他们拥有近 13000 名武装人员，
only seven of the 16 IRA divisions from the War of Independence are on the side of the Free State Government. So this looks like a fairly powerless position for the Free State Government. However, the Free State Government have the support of the British, and the British have an unending arsenal of weapons that they have accumulated from the First World War, and within like two months they've given the Irish 40,000 rifles. And can I ask, do the treaty-ites fight harder than the British had done with these weapons? Well, they absolutely did. Because they were fighting, I mean, most of those who had been involved in the black and
独立战争中 16 个爱尔兰共和军师中只有 7 个站在自由邦政府一边。所以这对自由邦政府来说似乎是一个相当无能为力的立场。然而，自由邦政府得到了英国人的支持，而英国人拥有从第一次世界大战中积累下来的用之不竭的武器库，在两个月内他们就给了爱尔兰 40000 支步枪。请问，条约派的战斗会比英国人使用这些武器时更卖力吗？嗯，他们绝对更卖力。因为他们在战斗，我的意思是，大多数参与黑白部队设施的人都是雇佣兵。他们真的没有利益在其中。这主要是为了钱。但临时政府、亲条约部队是为了他们的生存而战，他们是为了一个濒临夭折的婴儿般的国家的生存而战。而这个国家，埃蒙·德瓦莱拉，他是当选总统，我的意思是他是反对国家机构、军队的大部分人、爱尔兰共和军也反对它。
tansy facilities were mercenaries. They really didn't have a stake in this. It was mostly for money. But the provisional government, the pro-treaty forces were fighting for their survival and they were fighting for the survival of an infant state that was like threatened to be stillborn. And this state, Eamon de Valera, who was the elected president, I mean he's against what the state bodies, large sections of the army, the IRA, are against it as well.
那么宪法局势是怎样的？谁在指挥军队，谁在指挥政府？一旦德瓦莱拉和大量的爱尔兰共和军组织了对它的反对。好吧，临时政府有七名成员，凯文·奥希金斯有一句著名的描述：八个年轻人坐在
So what is the constitutional situation? Who is in command of the army and who is in command of the government? Once De Valera and large numbers of the IRA have arranged an opposition to it. Well, the provisional government is seven members, famously described by Kevin O'Higgins as eight young men sitting in the building government is seven members, famously described by Kevin O'Higgins as seven,
建筑物里，狂野的人在钥匙孔外尖叫，一个政府倒台了，另一个还没有组建。所以他们处于非常岌岌可危的处境，但他们的处境在 1922 年 6 月 16 日的选举中得到了加强，请记住，这仅仅是在威尔逊被暗杀前六天，反条约派在这次选举中惨败。对。他们只得到了不到 22% 的选票。爱尔兰大多数人只想继续他们的生活。
eight young men sitting in a, in the building with wild men screaming through the keyhole and with one administration gone and another one not formed. So they're in a very precarious situation, but their situation is, is, is strengthened by the June 1922 election on the 16th of June, bearing in mind, this is only six days before Wilson's assassinated, which the anti-treaty side are routed. Right. They only get less than 22% of the vote. Most people in Ireland want to get on with their lives.
他们不在乎誓言。他们不在乎。从第一次世界大战开始算起，他们已经经历了八年的战争。只想继续过日子。所以，英国政府抓住了这个事实，劳埃德·乔治和丘吉尔告诉临时政府，你们拥有统治的授权，放手去做吧。特别是对迈克尔·柯林斯，对吧？是的。
They don't care about the oath. They don't care. They've had eight years of war going back to the start of the first world war. Want to get on with things. So, and the British government grasps this fact and Lloyd George and Churchill are telling the Provisional Government, you have the mandate to govern, get on with it. And specifically to Michael Collins, right? Yes.
因为丘吉尔特别认为迈克尔·柯林斯是英国政府可以与之谈判的人。我说的没错吧，在 7 月 1 日，柯林斯宣布他将接任军队总司令。他也在政府中。我知道在我们的爱尔兰听众的语境下，这听起来可能是一个具有挑衅性的说法，但我想到了克伦威尔，一个反抗君主制的革命者，他推翻了君主制，然后面对议会议员和军事反对派的分裂，使得自己基本上同时指挥了军队和……仅供收听节目、看不到画面的听众了解，
Because Churchill in particular thinks Michael Collins is someone that the British government can negotiate with. And am I right that on the 1st of July, Collins announces that he is going to take over as commander and chief of the army. He's also in the government. And I know that this will sound maybe a provocative thing to say in the context of our Irish listeners, but I am reminded of Cromwell, a revolutionary against monarchy, whoever throws a monarchy and then faced with divisions among parliamentarians and military opponents makes himself essentially in command of both the military and the... Just for people listening who can't see
罗南刚才不得不被物理制止，以免对汤姆造成伤害。我的意思是，这个比喻有什么公正性吗？嗯，我认为基本上爱尔兰内战被构建为民主派与不支持民主的人之间的战斗。正如我所解释的，已经进行了三场赞成条约的民主投票，但反条约派站在了一边，多米尼克之前也谈到过这一点，埃蒙·德布洛涅说，人民没有做错事的权利，对吧？所以柯林斯在 7 月 1 日，正如你所说，
the pictures Ronan has just had to be physically restrained from doing injury to Tom. I mean is there any justice in that comparison? Well I think basically the Irish Civil War has been framed as a battle between Democrats and those who don't support democracy. So as I explained, there have been three democratic votes in favor of the treaty, but the anti-treaty was siding and Dominic talked about this before, Eamon de Boulogne said, the people have no right to do wrong, right? So Collins, on the 1st of July, as you say,
他成为了总司令，他也在政府中。他基本上，政府承担了独裁权力。6 月选出的议会直到 9 月才开会，因为发生了一场内战。我的意思是，你可以有同样的看法，你也可以说，为什么泽连斯基没有，乌克兰为什么会有选举？
he becomes commander in chief, he's in the government as well. He has basically, the government assumes dictatorial powers. The parliament that's elected in June, it doesn't sit until September because there's a civil war on. I mean, you could have the same, you could say as well, why isn't Zelensky being, why is there elections in Ukraine?
当有战争在进行、有内战在进行时，你不能举行选举。所以是的，他在那个时期确实承担了巨大的权力。但我想其中一种方式，我的意思是，他是其中许多方式中的一种，但一个非常显著的方式是，他实际上没有任何军事经验，不是吗？
You can't have elections when there's a war going on, there's a civil war going on. So yeah, he does assume a huge amount of power in that time period. But I suppose one way, which is, I mean, one of the many ways in which he's done like, well, but a very salient one is he hasn't actually had any military experience, has he?
没有。我们可以讨论他被枪杀时的环境。但可以肯定的是，国民军开始非常迅速地招募新兵。因此他们在人员和物资方面的任何劣势都很快消失了。我的意思是，他们基本上，与第一次世界大战没有什么不同，他们设立了招聘站，并得到了热烈的响应。当然，有很多，因为爱尔兰曾作为英国的一部分参加过第一次世界大战，有很多失业并寻找工作的退伍军人。
No. And that we can talk about that when it comes to the circumstances in which he shot. But certainly the National Army starts to recruit very quickly. So any disadvantages they had in terms of men and material is gone very quickly. I mean, they basically, not unlike the First World War, they have, they set up recruiting stations and there's a huge response. And of course, there's a lot of, because the Ireland had participated inside the UK, in the First World War, there's a lot of ex-servicemen who are unemployed and looking for a job.
让我们稍微看一下战争的进程。让我感到对反条约派或非正规军（正如他们被称为的那样）来说是一个大问题的是，如果你支持条约，如果你站在迈克尔·柯林斯一边，你确切地知道你想要什么。你想要条约，你想要自由邦，你只想重新开始生活。如果你反对条约，你的目标就有点模糊了，不是吗？你不是明确支持什么，你是支持一个独立的爱尔兰共和国这个模糊的概念。你认为这个政治问题在赢得战争方面对他们来说是一个大问题吗，反条约派？
So let's look at the course of the war a little bit. And something that strikes me as a big problem for the anti-treatyites or the irregulars as they're called is that if you support the treaty, if you're on Michael Collins' side, you know exactly what you want. You want the treaty, you want the free state, you just want to crack on again with your lives. If you're anti the treaty your goals are a little bit more nebulous, aren't they? You're not exactly for anything, you're for the nebulous idea of an Irish, independent Irish Republic. Do you think that political issue is a big problem for them in terms of winning the war, the anti-treaty?
是的，确实如此，因为现阶段共和国不是一个选项。正如我之前所说，大多数人已经被独立战争、复活节起义折腾得精疲力竭，他们只想继续他们的生活。你说得对，他们将其构建为反对某种东西的意义上，而不是拥有不同的方案。他们在谈论共和国，但英国人不会给予共和国。德瓦莱拉知道这一点。所以他想出了这个名为“二号文件”的想法。
Yes, it is because a republic is not an offer at this stage. And most people are, as I've said before, they're really ground on by the war of independence, the Easter rising, and they just want to get on with their lives. And you're right, they have framed it in the sense of being against something as opposed to having a different offering. And they're talking about a republic, but the British are not going to grant a republic. De Valera knows this. So he comes up with this idea called document number two.
他想出了这个主意，这和他们之间的分歧一样微妙。他谈到了外部联合。他进行权衡，因为他是数学家。他试图用所有这些饼图之类的方式来解释它。但基本上它的意思是自由邦与英联邦联合，但不是英联邦的一部分。因此英国君主不是国家元首，也没有效忠宣誓。这有点天才，不是吗？我的意思是，这有点行得通，但没有人，无论他的敌人是英国人还是亲条约派，都不会接受这种表述。完全正确，快进到 1927 年，当他被迫宣誓就职时，他
He comes up with this idea and this is as nuanced as the differences between them. He talks about external association. He draws because he's a mathematician. He tries to explain it with all these kind of pie charts and that. But essentially what it means is that the free state is associated with the Commonwealth, but not part of the Commonwealth. And therefore the British monarch is not the head of state and there's no oath of allegiance. Which is kind of genius, isn't it? I mean, mean it kind of works but nobody, none of his enemies, whether they're British or pro-treaty are going to accept that kind of formulation. Well exactly and fast forward to 1927 when he's forced to take the oath of office he
说这只是一张纸。如果他早在 1922 年就这么说，他就可以避免内战了。关于内战，反条约派的战略实际上是守住南部和西部。我们提到的利亚姆·林奇有一个怪物共和国的梦想。他基本上认为如果我们能守住南部和西部，那么剩下的就只有这个条约残余，这将变得不可行。他能做到这一点、拥有这个怪物共和国，这曾经现实过吗？不，这不现实。
says it's just a piece of paper. If he only had said that in 1922 he could have avoided the Civil War. So on the Civil War the anti-treaty strategy effectively is to hold the South and West. They have, Liam Lynch who we mentioned, has this dream of a monster republic. He thinks basically if we can hold the South and West then all that will be left is this treaty rump and that will become unviable. Is that ever realistic that he can do this, have this monster republic? No it's not.
这就是问题所在。你看这场战争，他们是在边打边摸索。我的意思是，无论任何人怎么说，双方都没有为战争做好准备。所以他们没有做出任何应急计划。因此，利亚姆·林奇谈到了在利默里克和沃特福德之间建立一条快速网线，该线以南的一切都是芒斯特共和国。但这在 1922 年 7 月和 8 月迅速被突破。爱尔兰陆军军官加尔·彭德加斯特有一本新书，他在书中谈到了这一点，以及他们如何能够如此迅速地压倒沃特福德和利默里克的守军。但也有战斗。
This is the problem. You see this war, they're making it up as they go along. I mean, no matter what anybody says, neither side is prepared for a war. So they haven't made any contingencies. So Liam Lynch talks about setting up a fast net in a line between Limerick and Waterford and everywhere south of that line is the Munster Republic. But that's quickly breached in July and August 1922. There's a new book by an Irish army officer called Gar Prendergast when he talks about this and how quickly they were able to overwhelm the garrisons in both Waterford and in Limerick. But there's also fighting.
实际上有两支军队在利默里克郡的基尔马洛克互相交战。所以这些一年前还并肩作战的家伙们互相交战，实际上有两支军队在利默里克郡的基尔马洛克互相交战，这是个非凡的景象。他们在利默里克郡的开阔地带作战。但一旦战争开始，胜算对反条约派完全不利。然后，对于常规作战来说真正具有致命一击意义的是国民军在科克进行两次、在凯里进行一次的两栖登陆。再次，他们在那里得到了英国人的帮助吗？是的，他们得到了。他们征用了几艘渡轮，并在英国皇家海军的护航下进入
There's actually two armies fighting each other in Kilmalloch County Limerick. So the extraordinary spectacle of these guys were fighting together a year previously, fighting, there's actually two armies fighting each other in Kilmalloc, County Limerick. So the extraordinary spectacle of these guys were fighting together a year previously and they're fighting over open territory in County Limerick. But the odds are all against the anti-treaty side once the war gets underway. And then in the coup de grace really for the sort of conventional operations of the war is the amphibious landings that the National Army have at twice in Cork and once in Kerry. And again, are they helped there by the British? Yes, they are. The commandeer a couple of furries and they have a British Royal Navy escort into
了科克的港湾。很明显，英国人站在国民军一边，他们希望国民军获胜。他们决定走海路去进攻芒斯特共和国的原因是，所有的公路和铁路都被摧毁了，爱尔兰共和军在战争中造成了大量的物理破坏。因此，随着大约 8 月 10 日科克市的陷落，那是内战中最后一次重大且戏剧性的标志性事件。所以实际上这一切在几周内就迅速完成了。显然，在内战中丧生的人中有三分之二死在前三个月。但这里有趣的是。内战并没有就此结束。反条约派认为，
the bays in Cork. So obviously the British are on the side of the National Army, they want the National Army to win. The reason why they decide to take to the sea to attack the monster republic is because all the roads and railways have been destroyed and there's a huge amount of physical destruction in the war done by the IRA. So with the capture of Cork City, which is I think the 10th of August, that's the last great sort of dramatic set piece of the Civil War. So actually it's been done and dusted very quickly in a matter of weeks. So apparently two thirds of those killed in the Civil War die in its first three months. But here's the interesting thing. The Civil War doesn't end there. The anti-Treatyites think, well,
我们现在可以恢复游击战了。没错。所以他们要对自由邦做他们对英国人做过的事，他们要设立伏击，也就是现在所谓的非对称战争。因此，与其说是承受失败，不如说是退守乡村。他们中的许多人现在是教条主义的共和国分子。无论发生什么，他们都不会放弃。尽管有和平试探，我们当时提到的埃蒙·德瓦莱拉认为比赛可能已经结束。
we can now just revert to a guerrilla campaign. That's right. So they were going to do to the Free State what they had done to the British, they were going to set up ambushes, what they call nowadays an asymmetrical war. So this is, instead of sort of taking their beating, so to speak, they retreat to the countryside. A lot of them are now doctrinaire Republicans. They're not going to give up no matter what happens. And even though there are peace feelers out there and we're talking about him and de Valero at that time was thinking that maybe the game was up.
但现实是战争将继续下去。他这时候在哪里？德瓦莱拉在哪里？说来有趣，当迈克尔·柯林斯被暗杀时，他实际上在科克，离柯林斯非常近。但德瓦莱拉在这个阶段被边缘化了。我的意思是，他点燃了火柴，但大火在他不知情的情况下烧了起来。在这个阶段，他基本上把控制权让给了军国主义者。在某种程度上，迈克尔·柯林斯也是如此，因为柯林斯是一个来自科克、来自爱尔兰西南部的人。
But the reality is that the war was going to continue on. Where is he at this point? Where is De Valero? Funny enough, he's actually when we come to the assassination of Michael Collins, he's actually in Cork, he's very close to where Collins is. But De Valero is kind of sidelined at this stage. I mean, he lights the match, but the conflagration goes off without him. And he's basically ceded control to the militarists at this stage. As to a degree, Michael Collins has too, because Collins is a man from court from the southwest
他是一个资助过某种阴暗的游击战、曾向英国王室军队发起挑战的人，现在他发现自己面对的是科克郡周围的叛军。他在打一场游击战。他使用的是英国人提供给他的枪支和弹药。我的意思是，他一定觉得这非常非常痛苦。对他们所有人来说都很痛苦。让那些曾与你并肩作战的同志们在一年之内互相残杀，这真的是一件超现实的事情，你杀死的其实是自己的亲骨肉。而且这撕裂了家庭。分水岭两侧都有家庭。
of Ireland. He's a man who has sponsored kind of shadowy guerrilla warfare, who has taken on the forces of the British Crown and now he finds himself facing rebels around County Cork. He's fighting a guerrilla war. He's using guns and ammunition supplied to him by the British. I mean, he must find this very, very painful. It's painful for all of them. It's really a surreal thing to have people that, you know, were your comrades in arms. And within the space of a year, you are killing people who are your own flesh and blood, really. And it splits families. There are families on both sides of the divide as well.
所以柯林斯是……柯林斯希望战争结束。我的意思是，这是我们在 1922 年 8 月他南下时问他的问题之一。他是试图结束内战吗？那么你认为他为什么在 1922 年 8 月去科克？他去科克有三个原因。第一个原因是他想去那里视察守军。他想看看发生了什么。第二个原因是他通过小道消息听说占据科克的反条约派从海关税收等方面拿走了巨额资金。
So Collins is... Collins wants the war ended. I mean, this is one of the questions we ask him when he goes down south in August 1922. Was he trying to bring an end to the Civil War? So why do you think he goes to Cork in August 1922? He goes to Cork for three reasons. The first one is he wants to inspect the garrison cellar there. He wants to see what's happening. The second reason is that he has heard on the grapevine that the anti-treaty side who had been occupying Cork had taken a huge amount of money in revenues from customs and so on.
当然，他曾任财政部长。他对这种事情非常警觉。他想把钱拿回来，至于他去那里是否是为了把双方捏合在一起，存在疑问。你听到了相互矛盾的报道，但他在 8 月 21 日（即巴林布洛事件前一天）确实写信给 W·T·科斯格雷夫。他说，你知道，人们不希望我们谈判，他们不想对当时所谓的非正规军进行任何妥协。他去那里也是为了，他想见见自己的人民。你知道，他是个地地道道的科克人。
Of course he'd been the finance minister. He's very alert to that kind of thing. He wanted to get the money back and there's questions whether he was there to try and bring bang heads and bring sides together. You hear conflicting reports about that, but he does write to WT Cosgrave on the 21st of August, the day before he's bailing a block. He says, you know, the people don't want us to parlay or they don't want any compromise with the irregular, as they're called at that stage. And he's also down there to, he wants to meet his own people. You know, he's a Corkman through and through.
他有，正如你在他生命的最后一天所看到的，他顺道去看了他很久没见过的家人。好吧，休息过后，我们将进入那一天的事件，我们将回顾柯林斯的行动和他的命运，然后我们将询问内战结束时发生了什么以及它是如何被铭记的。
He has, and you'll see on his final day, he's calling in and seeing his family he hasn't seen for a long time. Right, well after the break, we'll get onto the events of that day and we will go through Collins's movements and his fate, and then we'll ask what happens at the end of the Civil War and how it's remembered.
我们稍后会这样做。到时见。有普通的冰冷。还有远山泛蓝的冰冷。山泉爽口。库尔斯清淡啤酒。冰爽之选。理性饮酒。
And we'll do that in a few moments. See you then. There's regular cold. And then there's the mountains are blue cold. Mountain cold refreshment. Coors light. The chill choice. Celebrate responsibly.
必须达到法定饮酒年龄。本集由阿迪达斯赞助播出。当挫折感增长、怀疑开始潜入时，我们都需要一个支持我们的人。告诉我们会没事的。提醒我们的能力，去相信，因为他们对我们的信念转化为对自我的信念，并提醒我们自己所具备的一切能力。我们都需要有人让我们相信。话题标签：你能行的。
Must be legal drinking age. This episode is brought to you by Adidas. When the frustration grows and the doubts start to creep in, we all need someone who has our back. To tell us we'll be okay. To remind us of our ability, to believe, because their belief in us transfers to self-belief and reminds us of all that we're capable of. We all need someone to make us believe. Hashtag, you got this.
大家好，我是来自“历史其余部分之足球每日光芒”的米莉·布赖特和雷切尔·戴利。随着女足欧洲杯的进行，我们想告诉大家我们今年夏天将如何报道欧洲杯和所有比赛，以及在你的生活中拥有一点每日光芒意味着什么。对于那些不知道的人，我和米莉是 2022 年举行的欧洲杯上捧杯的英格兰队的一员，我们将提供所有见解和详细信息，关于营地里的生活是什么样的，以及女孩们今年夏天可能会经历什么。我们将讨论今年夏天锦标赛中产生的所有重大故事，
Hi everyone, Millie Bright and Rachel Daly here from the Restless Football Daily Brightness. With the Women's Euros underway, we want to tell you how we'll be covering the Euros and all the games this summer and also what it means to have a little bit of daily brightness in your life. For those of you that don't know, myself and Millie were part of the England team that lifted the Euros in 2022 and we'll be giving all insights and detailed information about what life is like in camp and what the girls may be experiencing this summer. We will be discussing all the big stories that come out of this summer's
并将为卫冕冠军的英格兰队加油助威。我们还将谈论我们在比赛之外的生活以及我们在做什么，无论是 DIY、在高尔夫球场上的时光、足球的高潮和低谷以及我们面临的挑战和我们永远感激的事情。这将是一个令人难以置信的激动人心的夏天，我们希望你能加入我们，和我们一起踏上这段旅程。只需在您获取播客的任何地方搜索“The Rest is Football, Daily Brightness”。不要忘记订阅，并在 Instagram 和 TikTok 上关注我们。欢迎回到《历史其余部分》。罗南，今天是 1922 年 8 月 22 日，迈克尔·柯林斯回到了他的家乡科克。请带我们了解那一天的事件。
tournament and we'll be cheering on England as they look to defend their title. We'll also talk about our lives outside of the game and what we get up to, whether it's DIY, time on the golf course, highs and lows of football and the challenges that we face and things that we are eternally grateful for. It's going to be an incredibly exciting summer and we'd love you to join us and come along the journey with us. Just search the Rest is Football, Daily Brightness, wherever you get your podcast. Don't forget to subscribe and also follow us on Instagram and TikTok. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. Ronan, it is the 22nd of August 1922 and Michael Collins has returned to his home county in Cork. Take us through the events of that day.
作为一个精力充沛的人，他早上 6 点 30 分就起床了。他们离开科克帝国酒店，这是一个非常大的队伍。他住在帝国酒店。是的，我知道。那里有一个迈克尔·柯林斯房间。哦，天哪。这给人的观感非常糟糕。所以他基本上是带着一大群护卫，坐在一辆敞篷的利兰旅游车里，随行的还有一个
So being the sort of energetic man that he is, he's up at 6.30 in the morning. They leave the Imperial Hotel in Cork and it's a very big contingent. He's staying in the Imperial Hotel. Yes, I know. And there's a Michael Collins room there. Oh my God. The optics of that are very bad. So he's basically going around with a very large escort in an open top Leyland tour and car with a
名叫埃梅特·达尔顿的人，他是攻占科克的将军，在 8 月份他只有 24 岁。所以他面前有非常忙碌的一天。他将去见他在西南部的几位指挥官。他还要去见一些朋友。他将尝试见一些亲条约派的人。关于这一点，尽管我们知道常规战争已经结束，但这仍然是非常强烈的反条约领土。柯林斯进入西科克这一部分是一个具有挑衅性的姿态。但就他而言，
man by the name of Emmett Dalton who is the general who takes Cork and he's only 24 years of age in August. So he's a very busy day ahead of him. He's going to meet some of his commanders in the southwest. He's also going to meet some friends. He's going to try and meet some of the people who are pro-treaty. And the thing about this is even though we know that the conventional war is over, this is still very much anti-treaty territory. And it's a provocative gesture on the part of Collins to go into this part of West Cork. But as far as he's concerned,
这是他的家乡，他是不会被拒之门外的。据称他说过很多杜撰的声明。所以我无法担保这一点，但他显然说过，他们永远不会在我的家乡枪杀我。于是他出发了，这是一场绝对的马拉松式的一天，并且遇到了很多问题。很多道路被封锁，树木倒塌。其中一辆车抛锚了需要修理。早上他们经过一个叫朗斯酒吧的酒吧，位于一个十字路口，就在一个将永远铭刻在爱尔兰历史上的地方——拜纳布洛——外面，他被一个附属反条约派的哨兵完全偶然地认出来了。
this is his home county and he's not going to be kept out of it. And he's alleged to have said there are many apocryphal statements. So I can't vouch for this, but he's apparently said, they'll never shoot me in my own county. So he goes off and it's an absolute marathon day and it's beset with a lot of problems. There's a lot of roads that are blocked or trees that are down. One of the cars breaks down and needs to be fixed. And in the morning they go past this pub called Long's Pub, which is at a crossroads just outside a place called, which will live an infamy in Irish history, is called Beil Nablot and he is spotted there by a sentry attached to the anti-treaty side entirely by coincidence.
那天反条约派在朗斯酒吧开会，有人认出了迈克尔·柯林斯，但当他们认出他时，他已经走了。所以他们当时伏击他的机会错过了。他接着去参观了老宅，去卡哈尔贝格看望他的表亲，他一直走到斯基伯林，那是一段非常非常长的路。这是带着一大群人去的。他在埃尔登酒店会见了指挥官，在回来的路上，他在萨姆十字路的“四全”酒吧停下来，给每个人买酒喝。
There's a meeting that day that the anti-treaty side have in Long's Pop and somebody spots Michael Collins, but by the time they spot him, he's gone. So the opportunity is lost for them to ambush him then. He then goes on, he goes visits the old homestead, he goes to visit his cousins in Carharbeg, he goes out as far as Skibberene which is a long, long way. And this is with a big contingent of men. He meets his commanding officers at the Eldon Hotel and then on his way back he stops at Sam's Cross, the Four Alls public house, and he buys drinks for everybody.
这是爱尔兰历史上最声名狼藉或最著名的饮酒聚会。他拜访了他的兄弟强尼，喝了酒，我们不知道喝了多少，但问题是，当他去度过他最后的时光时，他是不是有点喝醉了？对。他在“四全”酒吧喝了几品脱。他在拜访他的兄弟强尼。他状态非常好，他认为自己已经安全了，他们要回都柏林，他要在第二天恢复他的活动。但与此同时，当他一直在喝几品脱酒之类的时候，这些反条约派已经制定了他们的计划，不是吗？因为他们知道他很可能会沿着原路返回。是的。而这是每个陆军官员都会告诉你的事情，如果在敌方领土上，绝对不要走原路。但他别无选择，因为他们——是的，因为所有的道路——
It's the most infamous or famous drinking session in Irish history. He visits his brother, Johnny, and there's a drink take, and we don't know how many, but the question is then, is he a little bit sozzled when he goes to his final times? Right. He's had a couple of pints. He's had a couple of pints in the Four Alls public house. He's visiting his brother Johnny. He's in very good form and he thinks he's early in the clear and they're going to go
树木之类的，对吧？所以他们要建造一个路障，这是理想的伏击领土，对吧？路上有一个弯道。道路两侧非常陡峭。并且有人在为他放哨。当他在 8 点 30 分左右经过时，大部分人都已经散去了。我们认为大约是 8 点 30 分。当时肯定是暮色苍茫。接下来发生的事情是，剩下的反条约派人员（人数不多）开始战斗。
back to Dublin and he's going to resume his activities to follow one day. But meanwhile, while he's been having a few pints and whatnot, these anti-Treatyites have made their plans, haven't they? Because they know he's probably going to come back the same way. Yes. And that is something that every army officer will tell you, never come back the same way if you're in enemy territory. But he has no choice because they- Yeah, because all the road-
曾参加第一次世界大战的英国陆军退伍老兵埃梅特·柯林斯告诉柯林斯他们应该拼命开车，但柯林斯驳回了他们。柯林斯下车开始反击。接下来发生的事情仍然是个谜，但这次事件中只有一人死亡。那就是迈克尔·柯林斯。他头部中弹，
Trees and things, don't they? So they're going to build a block which is, it's ideal ambush territory, right? There's a bend in the road. It's very steep on both sides of the road. And there is a watch for him. And most of them have cleared off by about 8.30 as he passes the way. We think it was around 8.30. It was certainly twilight. And what happens next is that the anti-treaty men who were left, it's not a huge amount
就是这样，一颗子弹，一人死亡，我们相信这颗子弹是从大约 150 米外发射的，所以开枪的人一定是个训练有素的神枪手。有一个叫索尼·奥尼尔的人，很多人认为可能是他。是的，他是主要嫌疑人，在 1990 年由爱尔兰共和军情报部门的一名成员制作的纪录片中提到了他的名字。但有一个叫帕迪·卡利凡的人对此进行了自己的研究，他有一部名为《谋杀迈克尔·柯林斯》的舞台剧。他说不可能是丹尼斯·索尼·奥布莱恩，因为丹尼斯·索尼·奥布莱恩不是神枪手。他曾在德国战俘营呆过，他的食指活动能力丧失了 40%。所以那是黑手党还是古巴人干的？因此，他的理论是，他是被自己人枪杀的。
of them, start fighting. And Emmett Dalton, who is a former British Army veteran of the First World War, tells Collins that they should drive like hell, but Collins overrules them. Collins gets out of the car and starts shooting back. And what happens next is still a matter of conjecture, but there's only one fatality in this incident. That's Michael Collins. He's shot through the head
他自己人？在英国人的授意下？恕我直言，帕迪是我的朋友，他不让我这么说，但我倾向于不支持那个理论。但尸检没有进行死因研讯。有很多事情导致了这些年来的猜测，但我相信他是被反条约派枪杀的。这是一场可怕的悲剧。难道不是我们之前提到的更广泛的理论吗：柯林斯尽管身为总司令，
and that's it he's one bullet one fatality we believe the bullet was fired from about 150 meters away so whoever shot him must have been a trained marksman so there's a guy called Sonny O'Neill who a lot of people think it might have been yes so he is the chief suspect and he's named in a documentary in 1990 by one of the men who was part of the IRA intelligence. But there's a guy called Paddy Cullivan who's done his own research on this and he has a stage play called The Murder of Michael Collins. And he said it couldn't have been Denis Sonny O'Brien because Denis Sonny O'Brien wasn't a marksman. And he had been in a German prisoner of war camp and he had 40% loss of movement in his trigger finger. So was it the Mafia or the Cubans? So his theory is that he was shot by someone on his own side.
却从未真正在枪战中战斗过。从某种意义上说，他在这里有点像在过家家。是的，曾在索姆河战役中战斗过的埃梅特·达尔顿本身就是一个非常有趣的人，他曾站在爱尔兰另一位陨落的领袖汤姆·凯特尔身边，汤姆·凯特尔在索姆河战役中阵亡。汤姆·凯特尔曾被认为是一个地方自治爱尔兰议会的第一任领袖。所以埃梅特·达尔顿说，如果他早知道，如果他经历过冲突，他就会把头埋起来。他是这么说的。所以柯林斯的声誉在于让别人替他卖命。
His own side? At the behest of the British. With respect to Paddy, he's a friend of mine, he won't let me say this, but I'm not inclined to go with that theory. But the autopsy, there was no inquest. There were so many things that were done that have given rise to speculation over the years, but I believe that he was shot by the anti-treaty side. It was a terrible tragedy. And isn't the broader theory that we mentioned how Collins, despite being commander in chief,
他自己的人？在英国人的授意下。说句实话，帕迪是我的朋友，他不让我这么说，但我不太倾向于接受那种说法。但尸检没有进行死因研讯。多年来，有太多事情的发生引发了各种猜测，但我相信他是被反条约派枪杀的。这是一场可怕的悲剧。难道我们刚才提到的那个更广泛的理论不是说，柯林斯尽管身为总司令，
had never actually fought in a gun battle. In a sense, he's kind of playing soldiers here. Yes, Emmett Dalton, who fought at the Battle of the Somme, is a very interesting guy in his own right, and had been beside another lost leader of Ireland, Tom Kettle, who was killed at the Battle of the Somme. Tom Kettle had been talked about as the first leader of a Home Rule Irish parliament. So Emmett Dalton says if he had known, if he'd ever been in scrap, he would have kept his head down. That's what he says. So Collins's reputation is on getting others to do his bidding for him.
却从未真正在枪战中战斗过？从某种意义上说，他在这里有点像在过家家。是的，曾在索姆河战役中浴血奋战的埃米特·多尔顿本身就是一个非常有趣的人物，他曾陪伴爱尔兰另一位陨落的领袖汤姆·凯特尔，后者在索姆河战役中阵亡。人们曾讨论过让汤姆·凯特尔担任自治爱尔兰议会的第一任领袖。因此，埃米特·多尔顿说，如果他早知道、如果他曾经身处险境，他就会藏好自己的头。他是这么说的。所以柯林斯的声誉建立在让别人替他做事上。
So, and of course he'd had, I mean, that's why those pints are crucial, right? Yeah. That he's had a couple of drinks and perhaps his judgment is slightly impaired and make you a little bit more foolhardy than you would otherwise be. So here's the question with Collins. Collins is probably with De Valera, he's one of the single best known men in Irish, in modern Irish history. Does it matter that he was killed in August 1922?
所以，当然他当时也喝了点，我是说，这就是为什么那些品脱啤酒至关重要，对吧？是的。他喝了几杯酒，也许他的判断力有点受损，这让他比平时更有点孤注一掷。所以关于柯林斯，这里有个问题。柯林斯可能和德瓦莱拉一样，是爱尔兰、现代爱尔兰历史上最著名的人物之一。他在1922年8月被杀，这重要吗？
In other words, when you think about the trajectory of Irish history after the Civil War, what happens in the 1930s and 40s and so on, would Michael Collins Collins is existence have changed all that does it really matter that he was killed. I mean the most famous Possibly pseudo comment on this and you quoted in your book on Henry Wilson is the quotation from Supposedly a min de Valera which ends Neil Jordan's film on Michael Collins came out in 1996 Neil Jordan's film on Michael Collins which came out in 1996. De Villegas's mentor said it's my considered opinion that in the fullness of time history will record the greatness of Collins and it will be recorded at my expense. Yes, 1966 he's alleged to have said that. A lot of people would agree with that but to see the trouble with Collins is he's only 31 when he dies. He's not
换句话说，当你思考内战后爱尔兰历史的发展轨迹时，也就是30年代和40年代等等发生的事情，迈克尔·柯林斯的存续会改变这一切吗？他被杀真的很重要吗？我的意思是，关于这一点最著名的可能是假借的评论，你在关于亨利·威尔逊的书里引用过，那是据称来自埃蒙·德瓦莱拉的名言，这段话为尼尔·乔丹1996年上映的关于迈克尔·柯林斯的电影拉下了帷幕——尼尔·乔丹1996年上映的关于迈克尔·柯林斯的电影。德瓦莱拉的导师曾说：据我深思熟虑的看法，随着时间的推移，历史将会记录柯林斯的伟大，而这将被记录在我的牺牲之上。是的，据说他是1966年这么说的。很多人会同意这一点，但问题是，柯林斯死时只有31岁。他没有
tainted by the messy compromises and the disappointments that would inevitably become trying to rule a new state. But I do think that the history of Ireland would have been different had he lived. I feel that he's a much more dynamic, practical minded person. And very able. I mean very good at the kind of practical business of running a government. Yes, he was. And he was a trained banker and he trained in the post office as well.
受到那些试图统治一个新国家时不可避免会产生的混乱妥协和失望的玷污。但我确实认为，如果他活下来，爱尔兰的历史将会不同。我觉得他是一个更有活力、更具务实精神的人。而且非常能干。我是说，他非常擅长管理政府的那种实际事务。是的，他是。而且他是一个受过训练的银行家，他还在邮局受过培训。
And I think also what's really impressive when you read about him, say, going to the London to negotiate or whatever, or becoming involved in finance or military or whatever, is how quickly he learns. Yeah, he's he's he's just he's just a generational talent. And of course, when he dies, he's 31. And he's often cited, you know, what would what would Michael Collins have done, and so on. There was even a discourse to show you what that sort of called the ads on the imagination. There was an article in one of the Irish papers here. There's this incredibly arcane debate outside about about whether Irish
而且我认为，当你读到关于他的事情时，比如他去伦敦谈判什么的，或者参与金融或军事什么的，真正让人印象深刻的是他学习的速度有多快。是的，他他他——他简直是一个划时代的天才。当然，他死时才31岁。人们经常引用他的话说，如果迈克尔·柯林斯会做什么，诸如此类。甚至还有一种言论，向你展示这种所谓的对想象力的运用。这里爱尔兰的一份报纸上有一篇文章。外面有一场非常晦涩的辩论，关于爱尔兰的
Kamoge players, it's an Irish former Harland, should wear these things called Scorts, which are a cross between shorts and a dress or should they wear shorts. And the final paragraph in it is, well if Michael Collins was around he'd have shown the hypocrisy, the Komogi Association. And this is kind of, this is, this is, he's constantly evoked, oh you know he'd have done this, he'd have done that. I think, you know, you were in the great realms of the great man theory of history. I think the history of Ireland would have been different. It's certainly he would not have accepted partition the way his
卡莫吉（Camogie）球运动员——这是一种爱尔兰的女子棍网球——是否应该穿一种叫短裙裤（Scorts）的东西，那是短裤和裙子的结合体，还是应该穿短裤。而文章的最后一句话是，好吧，如果迈克尔·柯林斯还在的话，他就会揭露卡莫吉协会的虚伪。这有点，这有点，这——他不断被唤起，哦，你知道的，他会做这个，他会做那个。我想，你知道的，你正处于历史伟大人物理论的宏大领域中。我认为爱尔兰的历史会是不同的。毫无疑问，他绝不会像他政府里的同事那样接受分区。我认为这样说很公平。你认为如果他活着，天主教会会有同样的巨大影响吗？我的意思是，德瓦莱拉显然更有一种神职人员的气质。是的。你认为柯林斯会有所不同吗？我的意思是，他仍然是一个很好的天主教男孩。是的，我知道。我不这么认为。我认为如果柯林斯活下来，不同之处在于，他在试图在经济上建设爱尔兰等方面会更有活力。但我的意思是，人们一直在猜测。他对天主教的态度是怎样的？没有真正的证据表明他和其余的人有什么不同。这是一个非常天主教的国家。天主教会在这里拥有巨大的权力和影响力。我的意思是，他们基本上运营着
colleagues in government accepted partition. I think that's fair to say. Do you think the Catholic Church would have had the same degree of influence if he had lived? I mean de Valera clearly more sort of clerical temperament. Yeah. Do you think Collins would have been different? I mean he's still a very good Catholic boy. Yeah, I know. I don't think so. I think if Collins had lived, I think what would have been different was you would have been much more dynamic in trying to build Ireland up economically and so on. But I mean, people have always been speculating. Where was his attitude to the Catholic? There's no real evidence that he was any different from the rest of them. He was a very Catholic country. The Catholic Church had huge amount of power and sway here. I mean, they ran basically
医疗服务和教育服务，而且人们非常虔诚。所以你是否能改变这一点，我不知道。那么让我们回到更大的图景上来。柯林斯于8月22日被杀。但正如我们所说，战争在此之后的几个月里一直在继续，直到第二年夏天。尽管常规战斗已经结束，我们现在谈论的是游击战，但它现在有一种边缘感，一种恶劣感，是这样的吗？是的。所以，例如，临时政府开始进行简易处决。英国人，我想，
the health services and the education services and the people were very devout. So whether you could have changed that, I don't know. So let's get back to the wider picture. Collins was killed on the 22nd of August. But as we've said, the war continues for months afterwards until the following summer. Although the conventional fighting is over and we're now talking about guerrilla fighting, there is a kind of an edge to it now, a nastiness, is that right? Yes. So for example, the provisional government start summary executions. The British, I think,
在独立战争期间处决了24人。而临时政府处决了，我想，将近80人。现在这其中有一种真正的剑拔弩张之感。你认为这是因为双方在打长期的战争后都被野蛮化了吗？还是因为这是内战与反抗占领者战争的区别？又或者到底是什么原因？嗯，临时政府在很多方面不像英国人那样感到受约束。所以在1922年9月发生的事情是，政府出台了《公共安全法》，这基本上赋予了军事法庭审判和处决反条约武装力量的权力。反条约派则表示，任何通过这项立法的人都将被枪决。
has executed 24 people during the War of Independence. The provisional government executed, I think, almost 80. And there's a real edge to this now. And do you think that's because both sides have been brutalized by fighting the war for so long? Or is it because it's the difference between a civil war and a war against occupiers? Or what is it? Well, the provisional government didn't feel constrained in many ways as the British felt. And so what happens in September 1922 is that the government brings in the Public Safety Act, which is basically give military tribunals the power to try and execute anti-treaty forces. The anti-treaty side say that anybody who passes this legislation will be shot.
于是你们进入了这种针锋相对的杀戮阶段，回首过去，这些人怎么会像那样互相残杀，这看起来真是不可思议。因此，临时政府在1922年11月开始执行死刑，在几周内，他们就处决了厄斯金·奇尔德斯，他是一位非常著名的作家，《沙之谜》的作者，也是英爱代表团的秘书。他在他堂兄的家里被搜出一把手枪，然后他们处决了他。接着，最糟糕的方面是——因此，在条约签署整整一年后的12月6日，自由邦正式诞生了。
And so you enter this phase of tit for tat killings, which seem extraordinary when you look back at how these people could have turned on each other like the way they did. So the Provisional Government starts executions in November 1922 and within a few weeks they've executed Erskine Childers, who is a very famous author, the author of The Riddle of the Sands, who is the secretary of the Anglo-Irish delegation. He's found with a pistol in his cousin's house and they execute him. And then the worst aspect of it is, so the Free State comes into being officially a year after the treaty is signed on the 6th of December.
12月7日，支持条约的议员或TD（爱尔兰议会议员）之一肖恩·黑尔斯在这里的码头街上被枪杀，第二天早上，新成立的自由邦政府拉出了四名曾在四法院（Four Courts）待过的人，在没有任何审判借口的情况下对他们进行了简易枪决。所以叶茨说他们打起仗来就像，是什么来着，洞里的黄鼠狼还是什么的？当然，这不仅仅是自由邦对阵反条约武装人员。还有——尽管其规模据我所知非常有争议——宗派杀戮以及对新教徒的驱逐，这是这一时期巨大的社会转型之一。是的，是南爱尔兰非天主教徒的减少。没错。我想另一个
On the 7th, Sean Hales, who's one of pro-treaty MPs or TDs, is shot dead here on the Keys and the following morning, the newly established Free State government take out four men who had been in the four courts and shoot them summarily without any pretense of a trial. So Yates says that they're fighting like, was it weasels in a hole or something? And of course it's not just free state on anti-treaty fighters. There is also although the extent of it is I know very controversial sectarian killings and expulsions of Protestants and One of the great social transformations of this period. Yeah, is the decline of non-catholics in Southern Ireland? That's right. And I suppose the other
臭名昭著的——是的，没错。我想另一个臭名昭著的社会变化是被称为“大宅”（the great houses）的建筑的毁灭，也就是英爱统治阶层的庄园宅邸，包括亨利·威尔逊爵士的家族宅邸。是的。嗯，这些房子在独立战争中被烧毁，因为它们被视为英军驻扎的地方等等。但在内战中，反条约派烧毁了其中一百多座房子，除了纯粹的报复之外，没有任何合理的理由。亨利·威尔逊极力反对《英爱条约》的原因之一，是因为他相信在南方有30万我的新教徒或联合派同胞，
notorious Yes, right. And I suppose the other notorious social change is the destruction of what are called the great houses, the stately homes of the Anglo Irish ascendancy, including Sir Henry Wilson's family home. Yes. Well, these houses were burnt in the War of Independence because they were regarded as being places where British troops were billeted and whatever. There was no rationale for the fact that there was over a hundred of them burnt by the anti-treaty side in the Civil War, other than really revenge for whatever it was. And one of the reasons that Henry Wilson was so against the Anglo-Irish Treaty because he believed there are 300,000 of my fellow Protestant or Unionists
他们的命运将会如何？我想你可能会觉得得到了某种辩护，因为在1922年8月16日，也就是唐和奥沙利文被处决六天后，科里格雷恩庄园（Corry Grainhouse）被彻底烧毁，威尔逊家族此后永远离开了爱尔兰。他们并不是一个坏家族。我的意思是，大多数人，作为地主，他们在爱尔兰做了大量的好事，但他们走了，就再也没有回来。这是一件非常悲伤的事情。当然，还有一个问题，正如你所说的，很多大宅被烧毁了，自由邦一些政治家的许多宅邸也被烧毁了。
in the South, what's going to be their fate? And I suppose you might feel vindicated by the fact that on the 16th of August 1922, six days after Don and O'Sullivan are executed, Corry Grainhouse is burned to the ground and the Wilson family leave Ireland forever after that. And they were not bad family. I mean, most of the people, their landlords, they did an awful lot of good in Ireland, but they're gone and they never come back. And that's a really sad thing. And of course, there is the issue of a lot of the, as you said, the big houses were burnt and a lot of the houses belonging to some of the free state politicians were burnt
那是一个非常、非常、非常丑陋的时期。所以关于战争，关于战争的野蛮性，我一直在思考这个问题，在很多方面它似乎确实比独立战争更加野蛮。但接着我又想到了当代冲突。所以我们处于20世纪20年代初的东欧、波罗的海，有自由军团（Freikorps），当然还有希腊和土耳其，人们经常做的一个对比是芬兰内战，我想这场战争夺去了大约25,000人的生命。在短短三个月内。没错。
as well. It was a very, very, very ugly time. So on the war, the savagery of the war, so I was thinking about this, it does seem more savage in lots of ways than the war of independence. But then I was thinking about contemporary conflicts. So we're in the early 1920s in Eastern Europe, in the Baltic, with the Freikorps, Greece and Turkey of course, and a comparison that's often made, the civil war in Finland, which kills I think about 25,000 people. In the space of three months. Right.
按照这些标准，爱尔兰内战尽管血腥和残暴，但还是相当克制的。确实如此。我的意思是，死亡人数之少令人瞩目。鉴于当时的赌注有多大，你认为这是为什么呢？嗯，用霍布斯的经典名言来改写，它是污秽、残暴而短暂的。它只持续了11个月。被杀的人数刚超过1400人，这个数字不算巨大，但破坏是巨大的。
By those standards, the Irish Civil War, as bloody and as brutal as it is, is pretty restrained. It is. I mean, it's remarkable how few people die. And why do you think that is, given what is at stake? Well, it was, paraphrase Hobbes, nasty, brutish and short. It was only 11 months. And the number of people who were killed is just over 1,400, which is not a huge amount, but the destruction is massive.
而且被杀之人的才华也很高，你知道的，你谈论的是一些最优秀的人，迈克尔·柯林斯是最明显的例子，但他不是唯一的。而且它不像芬兰内战那样。你提到了西班牙内战或美国内战，它们持续了整整好多年。这也是为什么相对而言，爱尔兰能够在内战后相当快地恢复的原因之一。
And the caliber of people who were killed as well, you know, you're talking about some of the finest people, Michael Collins being the most obvious example, but he wasn't the only one. And it's not as it's not a civil war like the Finnish Civil War. You mentioned the Spanish or the American Civil War, which goes on for years and years and years. And that is one of the reasons why relatively speaking, Ireland's able to
所以它在——我们算是在1923年的春夏之交——结束了，IRA（爱尔兰共和军）参谋长利亚姆·林奇被杀。是的，他在4月被杀，对吧？没错，他的继任者弗兰克·艾肯下达了放下武器的命令，而德瓦莱拉则说，胜利属于那些摧毁了共和国的人。这是一种很戏剧化的表达方式。所以它与其说是结束，不如说是逐渐平息。没有停战协定，没有和平条约，什么都没有。
recover fairly quickly after the Civil War. So it ends in what are we the spring summer of 1923 the IRA chief of staff Liam Lynch is killed yeah he's killed in April isn't he? That's right and his successor Frank Aiken has a dump arms order and De Valera says you know victory is though with those who who have destroyed the Republic. This is a melodramatic way of putting it. So it peters out more than it ends. There's no armistice, there's no peace treaty, there's nothing like that.
它就这么结束了。但我想，仇恨和暴力以一种令人惊叹的速度被平息下来，其中有一个耐人寻味的方式，这或许也是柯林斯政权最大的成就，那就是在经历了前十年及更长时间里爱尔兰那种准军事化的警务工作之后，他建立了一种——我敢说——英国风格的警察部队，一种非武装的公民警察部队。这就是加达（Garda，爱尔兰警察）。这才是关键，对吧？第一次，你开始让不带武器的警察进入警察局，通过同意来维持治安，通过协商来维持治安，而爱尔兰绝大多数各种性格、宗教、观点的人，
It just ends. But one intriguing way in which I think perhaps the hatreds and the violence are pacified remarkably quickly and it's perhaps the greatest achievement of Collins's regime is the fact that after all the kind of paramilitary quality of policing in Ireland over the previous decade and more, he has instituted a kind of, dare I say, British-style police force, a kind of unarmed civic police force. And that that would be the gada. And that is key, isn't it? That for the first time you start to get on our policemen going into police station policing by consent, policing by consent, and the vast mass of people in Ireland of all temperaments, religions, perspectives,
某种程度上都接受了这一点。是的。很多人说这场战争是不必要的。它是不必要的，但它是决定性的。内战留下的最重要的遗产是，国家再也不会以同样的方式受到挑战。事实上，在1932年，政权从亲条约派和平过渡到了反条约派。因此，虽然它留下了痛苦的遗产，但国家存活了下来。我认为这是最重要的事情，国家存活了下来。内战真正残酷的遗产是，由于国家无法处理分区问题——因此在1925年之后，这个旨在划分边界的边界委员会成立了，原本预计它会将北方的很大一部分划给南方。
kind of accept that they do. Yeah. And a lot of people say that the war wasn't necessary. It wasn't necessary, but it was decisive. And the most important legacy that the Civil War left is that the state would never be challenged in the same way again. And in fact, in 1932, there's a peaceful transition from the pro to the anti-treaty side. So while it leaves a legacy of bitterness, the country survives. And I think that's the most important thing, that the state survives. The real cruel legacy of the Civil War is that because the state was unable to deal with the issue of partition, so the afters in 1925, this boundary commission that set up to draw the boundaries and had originally been anticipated would give large swathes of the north to the south.
它并没有这样做。而且因为自由邦政府如此贫困，自由邦政府实际上允许边界按原样保留，作为交换，获得了大约3000万英镑，这是爱尔兰分摊的英国帝国债务，因为爱尔兰政府破产了。这也是后来发生的“动乱”（the Troubles）的种子。我能否也为你朗读一段查尔斯·汤森（Charles Townshend）在他的书《共和国》（The Republic）结尾处写的话，他说，事实上，在逆境中，新生的爱尔兰国家——尽管对它的共和党受害者（也就是反条约派）来说显得多么暴虐——却变成了一个非常稳定的
It doesn't do that. And because the free state government is so impoverished, the free state government actually allows the border to stay in place as it is in return for about 30 million pounds, which was the Irish share of the British imperial debt, because the Irish government's broke. And that's also seeds for the troubles which occurs later on. Could I also just read you something that Charles Tansen writes at the end of his book, The Republic, and he says, in fact, and against the odds, the emergent Irish state, however tyrannical it seemed to its republican victims, so that's the anti-treatyites, became a remarkably stable
民主国家。它甚至可能过于稳定了。那些与共和国战斗到僵局的当权者，他们的想象力似乎因这段经历而缩小了。我想其中的刻板印象会是，德瓦莱拉的爱尔兰变成了一个贫瘠的荒岛。那是一个人们试图逃离的地方。是的，这是真的。我的意思是，如果你看看爱尔兰共和国自1922年以来的历史，你可能会发现前50年是成就不足的几十年，但接着你看看后50年，你就会充分体会到独立的成果，爱尔兰是一个非常稳定、富裕的国家。它和其他国家一样有自己的问题，但它是国际社会的重要组成部分，
democracy. It may even have been too stable. The status who battled the Republic to a standstill seem to have had their imaginative horizons shrunk by the experience. And I guess the stereotype of that would be that de Valera's island becomes kind of a craggy island. It's a place that people try to escape. Yeah, it's true. I mean, if you look at the history of the Irish state from 1922, you're probably looking at the first 50 years were decades of underachievement, but then you look at the next 50 years and you get the full measure of independence and Ireland is a very stable, wealthy country. It's got its problems like everybody else, but it's a full part of the international community,
可以这么说。所以这是非凡的。我的意思是，如果你去其他国家，比如西班牙，我去过西班牙，西班牙内战的遗产依然存在，但在爱尔兰并非如此。内战已经不再是一个分裂人们的问题了。
so to speak. So it is remarkable. I mean, if you go to other countries like Spain, I've been to Spain, and the legacy of the Spanish Civil War is still there, but it's not in Ireland. The Civil War is not, it's not an issue that divides people anymore.
在过去的25年里可能一直如此。尽管直到今天，爱尔兰的政党仍然由他们在其中扮演的角色来定义。是的，但他们现在都在政府里。所以你有芬娜菲尔（Fianna Fáil，共和党），它是反条约的，然后你有芬格尔（Fine Gael，统一党），它是亲条约的，但为了把新芬党（Sinn Féin）排除在外，他们一直在联合执政。是的，直到2020年。这一切都很混乱。我认为新芬党可能才是反条约派真正的遗产。
It probably hasn't been for the last 25 years. Although to this day, the Irish political parties are defined by the role that they played. Yes, but they're both in government now. So you have Fianna Fáil, which is which is anti-treaty and then you have Fianna Gail, which is pro-treaty, but they've been in government together to keep out Sinn Fein. Yes, to 2020. It's all very confusing. I think Sinn Fein would probably be the real legacy of the anti-treaty.
我可以问一个我认为会让我们的许多听众感到困惑、而我也一直很感兴趣的问题吗？那就是为什么德瓦莱拉——在某种程度上，他是我们谈到的大人物中最后一个屹立不倒的人。他支持了失败的一方，然而他却相当快地重新掌权。我的意思是，在不到一代人的时间内，他又回到了权力中心，然后他留任并统治了这个世纪。当他输掉了战争、也输掉了争论时，这怎么可能呢？是的，他输掉了争论，但基本上，明年就是芬娜菲尔党成立100周年了，
Can I ask a question that I think would puzzle a lot of our listeners and is often interested in me, which is why De Valera, he's the last man standing of the big characters that we've talked about to some extent. He had backed the losing side, and yet he gets back into power reasonably quickly. I mean, within a space of less than a generation, he's back in, and then he stays in and he dominates the century. How is that possible when he'd lost the war and he had lost the argument? Yes, he had lost the argument, but basically, essentially, next year is the 100th anniversary
他很快开始意识到，这种老一套的做法完全是任何政治进步的障碍。1927年，凯文·奥希金斯（Kevin O'Higgins）——顺便说一下，当我们谈到内战的残酷性时，他是下令处决其婚礼伴郎罗里·奥康纳（Rory O’Connor）的司法部长之一。罗里·奥康纳，凯文·奥希金斯在1927年被暗杀，这是内战的后续。当时的临时政府或自由邦政府说，如果你想参加议会，你就必须宣誓效忠。
of the founding of Fianna Fáil, he began to realize very quickly that this old thing was just a total impediment to any kind of political advancement. And 1927, Kevin O'Higgins, who by the way, and we're talking about the viciousness of the Civil War, he's the Minister for Justice who orders, one of them who orders the execution of his best man at his wedding, Rory O'Connor. Rory O'Connor, Kevin O'Higgins is assassinated in 1927, it's afters from the war. And the provisional government or the free state government at the time says, if you want to take part in the parliament, you've got to swear this oath.
而德瓦莱拉走了进去，宣了誓。然后，当然，科芒纳盖尔党（Cumann na nGaedhael）变得越来越不受欢迎，德瓦莱拉开始说我们会这样做，我们会那样做。到了20世纪30年代，即1932年，你知道的，很多事情已经被人们遗忘了，人们想要改变，同一个政府已经执政10年了。然后他开始瓦解这项条约，废除了效忠誓言。1938年，他收回了条约港口。这是英国人坚持保留的三个港口，丘吉尔说我们必须保留这些港口，而张伯伦说不，不，我们要把它们还回去。所以柯林斯完全是对的。
And de Valera walks in and he swears the oath. And then of course the Commonagale is becomes more and more unpopular and de Valera starts saying we'll do this we'll do that. And by the 1930s comes along, 1932, you know, a lot of it has been forgotten about the people want to change the same government has been in for 10 years. And then he starts to dismantle the treaty gets rid of the oath of allegiance. In 1938 he gets the treaty ports back. These are three ports that the British insisted on keeping and Churchill says we have to keep these ports and Chamberlain says no, no we're giving them back. So Collins was completely right.
是的，他是对的。他拥有一个岛屿，获得了自由的自由。是的，就是这样，我的意思是，我认为他已经被证明是正确的。当然，现在仍然挥之不去的一个核心问题是分区问题。这也是今天依然存在的一个活生生的现实话题。我的意思是，我对历史和内战进行了区分，内战是历史，而分区则是时事。对于相当多的人来说，它仍然是一个非常重要的议题。所以当60年代爆发动乱并在70年代加剧时，其中大量的语言和视觉语言都源自内战时期。
Yes he was. That he had one island, the freedom to come free. Yes and this is the thing, I mean I think he's been vindicated. The one abiding issue of course now of this is the issue of partition. And this is the issue that is still a life subject today. I mean, I make the distinction between history and the Civil War's history and partition, which is current affairs. It's still a very important issue for an awful lot of people. So when the troubles break out in the 60s and intensify in the 70s, so much of the language and the visual language of that derives from the Civil War period.
因此，临时爱尔兰共和军。正如柯林斯所说，菲尼亚斯人（Fenian）唯一需要的悼词就是枪手在坟墓上鸣枪。所有这一切都涌现出来了。从某种意义上说，这是一种非常、非常暴力的角色扮演（cosplay），对吧？是的，确实如此。事实上，20世纪70年代的临时爱尔兰共和军会说，他们是在延续反条约派的战斗。爱尔兰共和军在1923年之后从未真正消失。它只是转入了地下，并演变成了其他东西，
So the provisional Irish Republican Army. The shoot, as Collins has said about the only eulogy that Athenian needs is the gunmen firing over the grave. All this comes out. And in a sense, it's a kind of very, very violent form of cosplay, isn't it? Yes, it is. And in fact, the Provisional IRA in the 1970s would say that they were continuing on the fight from the anti-treaty side. The IRA never went away after 1923. It just became sort of went underground and morphed into something else
直到1969年。所以内战的结束和动乱的开始之间存在着直接的连续性。而且通读这段历史，你会发现所有的绝食抗议以及绝食抗议在爱尔兰独立故事中所扮演的角色。你会意识到，比如说博比·桑兹（Bobby Sands）和其他绝食抗议者的共鸣，我怀疑在英国，这基本上完全被忽视了，没有人理解这对爱尔兰共和党人意味着什么。是的，因为特伦斯·麦克斯维尼（Terence MacSwiney）是——你知道的，他是科克市长，1920年在布里克斯顿监狱绝食抗议而死。我的意思是，那是对这一做法的直接模仿，即1921年的绝食抗议。没错。罗南，你知道吗，我们要被赶出四法院了，不是用榴弹炮，而是
until 1969. So there's a direct continuity between the end of the Civil War and the beginning of the trouble. And also reading through this account all the hunger strikes and the role that hunger strikes play in the story of Irish independence. And you realize the resonance, say, of Bobby Sands and the other hunger strikers, that I suspect largely in Britain went completely, nobody understood the resonance of that for Irish Republicans. Yeah, because Terrence McSweeney was, you know, he's the Lord Mayor of Cork who died on hunger strike in 1920 in Brixton prison. And I mean, that was a direct imitation of that, the hunger strikes in 1921. Right. Ronan, you know what, we're going to be kicked out of the forecourt, not by howitzers, but
被一个想使用这个房间的高等法院法官。关于这一点——谢天谢地不是一枚重磅炸弹，只是一颗隐喻意义上的重磅炸弹——我们将这个伟大的系列节目画上了句号。罗南，你一直是一位出色的主持人和极佳的嘉宾。非常感谢你加入我们的“历史就是这样”（The Rest is History）。有你做客真是荣幸之至。我们期待了很久，它也确实没有辜负我们的期望。荣幸全在我和各位，先生们。非常感谢。
by I think a high court judge who wants to use the room. So on that, thankfully not a bombshell, only a metaphorical bombshell. We bring this mighty series to an end. Ronan, you've been a brilliant host and a great guest. Thank you very much for joining us on the rest of this history. It's been a huge pleasure to have you. We've been looking forward to it for a long time and it's lived up to our expectations. The pleasure has been all mine, gentlemen. Thank you so much.
谢谢你，罗南，再见。再见。再见。嗨，大家好。你们还在。就在节目的最后，我对你们的执着深表钦佩。但是听着，我有一个问题想问你们。我想私下问你们一件事。你们有时会听这些节目中的广告吗？你们有时会想，
Thank you, Ronan, and goodbye. Goodbye. Goodbye. Hi, everybody. You're still here. Right at the end of the episode, I'm very impressed by your commitment. But listen, I have a question for you. I want to ask you something in confidence. Do you sometimes listen to the adverts on these episodes and do you sometimes think,
你知道吗，我希望这个播客的听众，我希望他们听的是关于我的品牌的广告，而不是汤姆和多米尼克在这里推广的其他东西。如果你有过这种想法，当然只有一种方法可以知道那会是什么样的体验。你可以打破广告的常规。你可以成为下一个汇丰银行尊尚客户（HSBC Premier），或是曾在“历史就是这样”节目中做过广告的许多其他卓越公司之一。你可以通过在“历史就是这样”以及Goalhanger网络的其他节目中投放广告，将你的品牌展现在数百万志同道合的听众面前。现在你可能会想，我不知道什么是Goalhanger网络。
do you know what, I wish that the listeners to this podcast, I wish they were listening to an advert about my brand rather than the other stuff that Tom and Dominic are promoting on here. If you have thought that, there is of course any one way to find out what that would be like. You can disrupt the procession of adverts. You could be the next HSBC premiere or the many other tremendous companies that have advertised on the rest is history. And you could put your brand in front of millions of like-minded listeners by advertising on the rest is history and indeed the other shows on the Goalhanger Network. Now you may be thinking, I don't know what the Goalhanger Network is.
Goalhanger正是打造这个节目的公司。如果你正盘算着提升自己品牌的价值，Goalhanger非常希望能听到你的声音。你可以立即访问 GoalHanger.com 注册你的兴趣，或者你公司的兴趣。那是 Goal，拼写是 G-O-A-L，Hangar，拼写是 H-A-N-G-E-R，点 com。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。
Goalhanger are the company behind this very show. And if you are in the market to increase the value of your brand, Goalhanger would love to hear from you. You can register your interest or indeed your company's interest by going to GoalHanger.com right now. And that is Goal, G-O-A-L, Hangar, H-A-N-G-E-R, dot com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Goalhanger 是制作这档节目的公司。如果您有提升品牌价值的需求，Goalhanger 非常乐意听取您的意见。您现在就可以访问 GoalHanger.com 登记您或您公司的意向。网址是 Goal，G-O-A-L，Hangar，H-A-N-G-E-R，点 com。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。